how romantic it must be to get
imprisoned in a castle of me to squeeze
out to airs
hey guys Pete here but who can presume
to know the heart of a dragon this is
something that Arch maester gildane the
fictional character who wrote the
fictional account of House Targaryen and
Fire and Blood said a couple of
different ways talking about things
their dragons do after this episode you
could certainly apply this question to
the characters but perhaps in relation
to Damon who could presume to know
what's going on inside this guy's head
he's been crowned the king of the narrow
sea which is also the name of episode
four and after doing what he set out to
do in the stepstones he's decided to
bring his particular brand of chaos back
to King's Landing that provides fertile
ground for the show to do some character
development that those of us who read
ahead know will pay dividends later and
an episode that's almost as hard to
watch as it is beautiful it provided
answers to some questions that the
source material left readers to ponder
and I'll be getting into everything that
happened and why I liked it so much
right after I warned you about spoilers
if you haven't watched House of the
dragon's fourth episode yet then this
video won't be for you I will be
referring to the books the show Game of
Thrones and the history of this world
but I won't be revealing any future
spoilers that I know about by reading
ahead and with that out of the way let's
get into it the episode opens with the
princess of dragonstone's World Tour to
find a proper match this is something
that viseris set up because he wanted
her to have a choice in who she married
and based on the two candidates we see
at Storm's end pretty much anyone who
thinks they might have a remote chance
is making their case we meet an old man
from house dundarian you'll remember
that name from the original series from
the character Barrick who Ned sent to
hunt down the mountain and then later
became the resurrected leader of the
Brotherhood without banners his ancestor
mentions their estate blackhaven and
that is where Kristen Cole's father
worked as a steward when he he's talking
about it she brings up his meeting her
great-grandmother Queen Alison there 50
years ago which is good for a laugh and
also makes it clear that she's not
interested in someone who's older than
her father the next non-age appropriate
candidate is younger than her and she's
not much interested in him either but
does at least crack a smile when he
tells her that he'll protect her this
young man is from house Blackwood and we
see him get heckled by someone from
house Bracken where things escalate
until violence breaks out the few
between these two families is something
that's ongoing and always sort of in the
background in the riverlands as the
young man points out here the Blackwood
family is tied to the first men they're
the only family in that area that
worship the old gods and they have what
has to be one of my favorite sigils with
the weirwood tree on it plus it's a name
worth remembering because there are some
memorable characters that come out of
this house in the future in the books
there's mentioned of a duel between a
Samwell Blackwell and Amos Bracken at
this time but based on the way this ends
I'm not sure that it's supposed to be a
one-to-one adaptation either way the
violence sets things in motion and she
decides to leave and go back home two
months early and on the way there she
sees that Damon has also returned when
karaxi's buzzes her ship something I
noticed they're doing this season which
I didn't mention in last week's video is
illustrating this idea of the physical
presence a dragon has in space I like
how they lean into that here as they
sort of hit the deck as it flies by and
speaking of presence the look on beceros
and raniera's faces as they await Damon
in the throne room speak volumes about
the way his being there has potential to
stir things up he comes in wearing a
crown which viserys takes issue with as
the king would but after he bends the
knee handing over that and the
stepstones his brother warms up it's fun
to watch every everyone hold their
breath as he's walking with black fire
and they're sort of waiting for him to
actually welcome him and you know that
deep down even though Damon makes things
difficult this is exactly what viserys
wants
Corliss is sailing home and Damon
returning to King's Landing brings up
the question viserys asks who's holding
the stepstones and apparently it's no
one but with the crab feeder and his
army wiped out they won't be shaking
anyone down for the time being there is
a question because he was backed up by
the triarchy of how they feel about this
and we'll have to wait and see if the
show brings that up again as mentioned
viserys is pumped up to have his brother
back in town and actually appears to be
happy which is rare he brings the cold
shoulder when renera tries to join their
conversation because he's not happy that
she ditched the tour and when Alison
tries to smooth things over he gets
obnoxious there's a subtle touch here
that I think really justifies switching
out the actors for these roles when they
get older I've seen a lot of people
saying they're gonna really miss these
actors which is understandable but I
think this is a decision that makes
sense in this sequence we're looking at
the queen of the Seven Kingdoms and its
Future air they're dressed for their
respective roles at court decked out in
the best that money can buy and even
though they look fantastic they still
resemble the kids we met in the early
episodes because we have moved ahead
four years in the timeline by now and if
you think back to Storm's end in the
Blackwood and Bracken dispute with a
sword in his hand the kid in that
situation was fully capable of gutting
his Tormentor these are capable
characters who have a lot more agency
than their lower class counterparts but
they're not fully formed adults not yet
and so I like that there will be that
distinction in somebody else playing the
role when they get there because that's
the case renera can be impulsive and in
that way a frustrating young woman
making decisions based just on what she
wants and can get because of who she is
but can also have some legitimate issues
with the situation she finds herself in
Allison makes a fair point that most
people in this world don't get too
suitors let alone essentially every
eligible bachelor in the kingdom and
raniera levels Affair response saying
they aren't fawning over her they just
want her name and bloodline to raise the
stature of their houses and their
offspring when she just about how
romantic it must be to get imprisoned in
the castle to squeeze out heirs that
hits a little too close to home for the
queen and there's a great shared
reflective silence here just before she
asks how angry her father is he is
pretty angry but this conversation is
more about each of their roles not
really fitting so even at the top of the
food chain you can understand that
things are not ideal before they part
ways we get a brief indication that some
part of their old friendship still
exists when rainera says I've missed you
too and grabs her hand and this makes me
wonder about the scene that they
apparently cut from the last episode
where renera helped Allison get ready
for her wedding some of the images from
that popped out online this week and as
I mentioned and it does make you wonder
because of these time jumps it's a
little hard to see where these two are
at in their relationship in high
Valerian she has a conversation with her
Uncle who she hasn't seen for a very
long time he tries to explain to her
that marriage is only a political
Arrangement and that once she does her
Duty she'll be free to do whatever she
wants because she was born a Targaryen
she points out that for women there are
other things to take into consideration
because marriage can be a death sentence
like it was for her mother on the plus
side renera is actively sitting in on
the small Council meetings now and there
we learn that Corliss has plans to marry
his daughter to the Sea Lord of
braavos's son that would mean that the
crown would have to seek out a marriage
pact of their own to neutralize any
threat from his Naval power this would
mean that Lionel strong had the right
idea and that she would have to marry
Lenor which based on the look she makes
doesn't appear to be something she he's
interested in
when she goes back to her room she finds
a bag with a disguise and instructions
she finds the entry point to one of
magar the cruel secret passages that we
saw Varys and other characters use in
Game of Thrones and when she makes it
outside she finds Damon there waiting
for her he takes her on what starts out
as an exciting night on the town which
is cut with Allison taking care of a
crying baby bathing her husband who is
having some problems based on the sores
we see and then getting called to his
room for some passionless sex late at
night renera has some legitimate fun and
even runs into Harwin strong who seems
to be on board with keeping her secret
and she sees a Mummers show where the
crowd is convinced that baby aegon would
be the better choice to be their ruler
it's notable that she says that what
they want is of no consequence but all
of this is overshadowed when Damon takes
her inside one of the brothels where he
also takes off her hat to reveal her
Targaryen hair and blows up her whole
disguise he explains to her that this is
where people come to take what they want
and this is all a continuation of what
they were talking about before he talks
about pleasure and them being able to
sleep with whoever they want and then
things get intense where he starts to
get her going taking their relationship
to a brand new level but then he leaves
before things go all the way he leaves
her there and she gets spotted on the
way out and we'll see this kid who works
for Missouri take the information to
Otto for a reward when she gets home her
personal protector Kristen Cole is
surprised to see her outside the room
and she gets the idea to invite him in
in a really thoughtfully put together
scene we see that she initiates the
process of him becoming her lover how
this all played out was one of the
biggest questions I had about the early
part of rhaenyra's story and as I
mentioned in my trailer video last week
based on fire and blood's format of
relying on these different unreliable
perspectives it really was up in the air
and without going back into all of that
I'll just say that I absolutely enjoy
how they played with that to the point
that you can see how those different
versions would come into being after
being filtered through the perspectives
of those different chroniclers and again
I think it was all put together really
well I appreciated how Kristen sort of
paused at each of the multiple steps
involved in getting out of his armor to
point out that he does have honor he
realizes the potential mistake he's
making by breaking his oath but at the
same time he can't muster up what's
necessary to deny her there's certainly
been hints that it was going that way
especially in the third episode and so I
think there's enough there that you can
see that they have a connection Damon
wakes up in a flea bottom room that's
been arranged by mazaria and I
absolutely love the way that how he got
there and how much he knows about what
she's up to is left open for
interpretation was this something he set
up to try to turn his brother against
Otto or did he just go out and get
loaded and then she capitalized on the
moment it's something I've been thinking
about since I first watched the episode
and honestly can't say for sure either
way I also loved her line that hard
lessons are not welcomed but suffered
things are still icy between them after
what we saw play out at Dragonstone she
mentions that she left the skin trade
behind and we do see her collect her
payment for the information from Otto
and then she tells him he can pay for
the room on his way out before he takes
that information to the king you see
that Otto has a moment in his Chambers
where he isn't sure he goes to him and
it's interesting that when he hears that
she was in a pleasure house he doesn't
seem to mind that part at all but then
Otto explains that it was more than that
when pressed he says that she was seen
with her Uncle Dame women in the bowels
of a pleasure house and then adds
coupling after a dramatic pause viserys
gets defensive and calls him out for his
ambition of wanting his own blood on the
throne so badly that he would destroy
his then he sends him away and since she
spent the night in his Chambers Allison
overhears the whole conversation she
calls for rhaenyra and they have a
conversation in the godswood she asked
her if she did the deed with Damon and
when renera says that it's a vile
accusation she responds that the
targaryens do have queer customs and
Damon certainly knows no limit what's
fascinating here is that of course she
has to downplay what really happened and
she can tell her honestly that they
didn't have sex even though it seems
obvious that she would have if things
went that way so we see her spinning
things around somewhat to reassure not
only her friend but her Ally all while
knowing that she did have sex with a
member of the kingsguard who was
breaking his vows and you see her
Implement some of the tools she has here
because of her power she's quick to
point out people questioning the
princess's virtue and spreading Slanders
in a way that most people wouldn't be
able to when Damon wanders back in
through the gates he's escorted
forcefully by the kingsguard and left on
the floor of the throne room viserys
wants answers but he never gives any and
lets every chance he's given to deny it
pass right by it's all a little
maddening to watch until he proposes a
plan that makes it all make sense he
tells his brother to give him rhaenyra
to marry as a way to solve his problem
he frames it in a way that it doesn't
matter what people think because he's
the dragon and it's not hard for viserys
to see that it's not about rhaenera at
all but about the power she represents
it's a nice little echo of what she was
saying to Allison earlier Damon presents
this as a way to return the house of the
Dragon to its proper Glory his still
solution totally fits with what we've
seen of the character who as I mentioned
at the very beginning does a lot of
things that are hard to parse while he's
doing them a little bit later when
talking to Allison viserys will ask what
does he gain by admitting to something
he didn't do here and while it's not
clear if Damon actually knows what he's
trying to do or if he's just rolling
with the punches that come up because of
the way his chaos kind of creates all
these situations he always lands on the
side of trying to improve his position
in the end the king sends him away again
and as mentioned Allison does go to bat
for rhaenyra viserys maintains that
she's not innocent in this situation and
that her and Damon have the blood of the
Dragon which makes them restless and
chaotic still Alison is convinced by her
friend she swore to her that she remains
a maiden and she believes her when he
finally talks to his daughter he shows
her aegon's dagger which we find out
here also belong to Anar Targaryen which
is interesting because his daughter
danis's dream is what got them to leave
valyria before the Doom that's why they
left and subsequently is the reason that
all targaryens need to pay attention to
their dreams and can't completely write
them off they literally wouldn't be here
right now if they hadn't followed this
one that their ancestor had all those
years ago we do see that aegon added his
prophecy to the blade so that when it's
heated up you can read it and this is
something else that I talked about in my
trailer video so I won't go back down
that road she does agree to Wed Lenor
but only if her father removes Otto as
his hand she rightly recognizes that he
will continue to be a threat to her
becoming the queen and if she was going
to have to marry this guy anyway then
why not neutralize your political
enemies in the process her father
follows through with this he calls Otto
in and gives him his walk papers there's
another little lower dump here where he
talks about his father and some of the
stuff that was going on around the time
of his death he goes as far as saying
that Otto may have been involved with
that but I think what stands out more
here is that he says that he realizes
that Allison was a calculated
distraction he'll never get over losing
his wife and Allison being there is what
got him through to the other side so it
took him a little while to recognize
what was actually happening there and I
love the mirroring here of Otto lying to
the king in the same way that renero was
lying to Allison of course he was trying
to get his grandson on the iron throne
and he did send Allison as a calculated
distraction but at the same time he did
receive this information about rhaenyra
and what was he going to do keep it from
the King and so his run as hand that
started back in the reign of jaharis has
officially come to an end and that means
that we'll be getting a replacement for
him in the next episode and the episode
ends with the grand maester bringing
ranera Moon T this is a concoction that
exists in this world to prevent or abort
pregnancies and it kind of works as a
punch in the gut for the princess
because it means that her father doesn't
necessarily believe that she didn't
sleep with her uncle
so I really like this episode for
multiple reasons as someone who spends a
lot of time thinking about TV not just
someone who has spent a lot of time
inside this world some of the things
that had been bothering me some of the
nitpicky stuff that had been standing
out in the past couple of episodes seem
to be less prevalent here part of that
could be because this is mostly a
self-contained episode and the chances
they're taking here are mostly on the
Character level part of it could be
because I prefer the style of this
director as opposed to the one who did
episodes two and three I thought the
dialogue was sharp and the actors all
delivered and some interactions that
were very layered I've been high on the
intentionality of what they've been
showing us in the first three episodes
and this is where I'm starting to really
love what they're doing with these
characters I don't think they can get us
to a place where they are any more
likable than they are right now and I
don't think it was ever going to be a
problem to present them as quad
characters but ones where you could at
least understand what they're doing and
for it to make sense based on the
circumstances but this week it felt like
they can make them complicated in a
compelling way I'm a sucker for
characters who can be two things at the
same time because that's what real
people are like and some of the time
that's a tough sell when you're dealing
with people whose magic blood affords
them the privilege of being royalty and
on top of that have their own personal
nuclear option I can be sympathetic
towards ranera who isn't being viewed as
legitimate based on her sex and the very
real problems she confronts because of
that fact but it doesn't necessarily
wipe all that other stuff away the show
seems to have that on its mind on some
level and I really appreciate that they
made the point of her having legitimate
fears about getting married and
producing errors in relation to what
happened to her mother this is not just
a spoiled brat only concerned with doing
what she wants to do she is that but
also has real concerns that she might
die fulfilling her Duty and then that
all comes back around to the real
problem of what happened in that room
with her mother based on what we know
about the character she did view that as
doing her Duty and possibly would have
told them to go ahead with the C-section
but she was never given a choice it was
never her choice rather than an
explanation about what was happening
even if it all might have been
inevitable someone else made the choice
for her and then they held her down
while she experienced what could only be
described as Terror as she became a
sacrifice as far as the lore end of
things like I mentioned getting answers
to some of these questions was an
absolute treat it was also great to see
Storm's end and a little bit of house
Blackwood who I am a big fan of as a
slight spoiler I'll say that I think
that the young man we saw there will
actually be the father of a pretty
important character that comes up much
later there's a ton of great
foreshadowing in that way and there's
even a pretty revealing Easter egg that
I won't point out but I think it will be
one of those things that when you go
back when you've seen the end of the
series you'll be like oh well then that
was right there the whole time the Damon
of it all is fascinating in a way that I
didn't think it could have been I mean I
knew this would be an entertaining
character but some of the stuff that
happened in this episode really had me
thinking I mean viserys was spot on in
him understanding that Damon was
interested in power there are multiple
things going on with all of that that
happened with rhaenira but at the bottom
of it all he's looking for a way in with
the way that they used massaria in this
episode though it's possible that he
planned this out a lot more than I would
have given him credit for based on the
character and some of the things that he
does in the book I don't think it's a
spoiler to say he's going to play a big
role in the rest of the series and I do
find myself more interested in what they
might do with him and I think that's a
great place to leave things let me know
in the comments what you thought about
this episode and if you haven't read the
book where do you think things are going
to go next if you have read it how do
you feel about these answers we got this
week and the additional characterization
that they're adding and the way that
they're filling in those blanks because
for my money they really are pulling it
off right now making this a much more
satisfying story for TV it's all right
to talk about book spoilers in the
comments just make sure you mark them so
that it won't spoil anyone who hasn't
read them please like this video If you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon